Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad,
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab this hour
talking about [inaudible] bird's lots of
words. So once words into your head,
once they tickle in there and we've
just explained how that happens sort of,
then they are, you know, they're
always, they're like, well,
what if they're not?
What would happen if that who
that throng that is in your head.
Yeah.
What if all of that stuff, whatever
is in your head suddenly went
get yanked right out of your head.
[inaudible] what would be left?
Hello.
This got us thinking about a very
famous time at probably one of the Ted
conferences I grew up the study of the
brain talk given by an euro anonymous
named Jill bolty. Is it bolty
or bulte? Bowtie Taylor. Yeah,
and all you really need to know is that
one morning in December of 1996 Dr.
Taylor woke up and she
had, she had a headache.
I woke up to a pounding pain behind my
left eye and it was the kind of pain,
caustic pain that you get
when you bite into ice cream.
And it just gripped me and
then it released me and it
was very unusual for me to
ever experience any kind of of
pain. And so I thought, okay,
I'll just start my normal routine.
So I got up and I jumped
onto my cardio glider,
which is a full body full exercise
machine and I'm jamming away on this thing
and I'm realizing that my hands look like
primitive Claus grasping onto the bar.
And I thought, Whoa, I
am a weird looking thing.
So I get off the machine and I'm standing
in my bathroom getting ready to step
into the shower and now I lost my balance
and I'm propped up against the wall
and I'm asking myself, what is
wrong with me? What is going on?
And in that moment, my right arm
went totally paralyzed by my side.
In fact, a blood vessel in the
left hemisphere of Jill's brain had
popped up and that part of your brain
was starting to shut down and it was the
shutdown that really caught our attention.
In that moment. My brain
chatter went totally silent,
just like someone took a remote
control and pushed the mute button.
So here I am in this space and my job
and any stress related to my, my job,
it was gone and I felt lighter in my body.
And then all of a sudden my
left hemisphere comes back
online and it says to me,
hey, having a stroke and we got to
get some help. And I'm going, oh,
I got a problem, I've got a problem. So
it's like, okay, okay, I got a problem.
But then I immediately
drifted right back out.
And I affectionately refer to this
space as la La land. But it was,
I'm just watching my brain
become more and more, uh,
I'm incapable of at is Jill both
detailer herself. Hi Robert.
We actually got her into a
studio. Hello Dad. Hello.
Cause we wanted to ask you some questions
about that moment when her inner
voices went away. So let's,
let's talk about brain
chatter for a moment in the
story that we've told so far,
you're still asking yourself questions.
Know did that stop it on
the morning of the stroke?
I was doing this wafting dance between
the right hemisphere and the left
hemisphere. So language
would come back on.
But once I got to the emergency
room and I passed out,
when I woke later that afternoon,
I had absolutely no language.
Did you know your name? No.
Did you know your address? No.
Did you know about your summer from
1983 you know like my mom is so and so.
Any of them? None of it.
I didn't know any of that.
Just imagine she's lying in her bed.
Her head is shaved, wrapped in bandages.
She's had hours of brain surgeries,
got tubes coming out of her mouth,
however knows she's lost her
career. She's lost her language.
I lost all my memories and yet she says,
sitting there in that
suddenly wordless space,
I had found a peace inside of
myself that I had not known before.
I had pure silence inside
of my mind. Pure silence,
pure silence. Hear silence. What you know,
not that little voice that that you know.
You wake up in the morning and the
first thing your brain says is, Oh man,
the sun is shining. Well imagine that
you don't hear that little voice saying,
man, the sun is shining and you just
experience the sun and the shining
does. Is this the absence
of reflection of any kind?
Is it just central intake and
that is exactly what it was. It was.
It was all of the present moment.
Did you have FOBTs I had joy. I had,
I just had joy. I had,
I had this magnificent experience of
I'm this collection of these beautiful
cells. I'm organic. I'm
this, this organic entity.
You have a period by any chance. You know,
I missed that by a few years,
but I get a lot of that.
And the other thing that she told us is
that lying in that bed with outwards,
she says she felt connected to things,
to everything in a way
that she never had before.
Oh yeah.
I lost all definition of myself in
relationship to everything in the external
world.
You mean like you couldn't figure out
where you ended [inaudible] how much of
that was was about language
of little part a lot.
I mean, oh,
I would say it was huge languages
and ongoing information processing.
It's the constant reminder
I am, this is my name,
this is all the data related to me
are the my likes and my dislikes.
These are my beliefs. I am an
individual. I am a single. I'm a solid.
I'm separate from you.
This is Rudy as this may sound
pin all of this on language.
We have run into this idea before
a couple of seasons ago. Uh,
Paul Brock's remember him. Yeah.
Neuro-Psychologist trust me about myself.
He told me that there is a theory out
there which she believes actually that all
a person is in the end, like
all the personhood of a person,
the I or the you of a person.
All that is in the end is a story.
A story you tell yourself we normally
think of when we think about ourselves is
really a story. It's the story of
what's happened to that body over time.
I did not have that portion of my
language centers that tells a story.
Here he is little Jill, Jill Bolte Taylor,
climbing the Harvard ladder through
language loves does section cutting up
thing. That language was gone. I
got to essentially become an infant
again. This is the problem here.
What do you mean when you drop out of
the ins of yourself or the story of
yourself, then you are
left. She says that piece,
I could argue that that's just stranded.
That's stranded in the sunshine
with the wind in the now.
But I mean it's not like she stayed there.
That's to me wouldn't be a dog to her if
she had, and as she started to recover,
she ran into something
kind of interesting,
which sounded to me sorta like what?
Maybe the rats and the babies
go through in the white room.
She would have these disparate thoughts
and then go back and remissed all out.
Like she couldn't bring them together.
When, when people would speak to me,
I would, I remembered in pictures. So, um,
if somebody would ask me, who is the
president of the United States of America?
This is a huge question.
So for the next several hours I'd
be pondering president, president,
president wants a president.
And then I would get a picture in
my mind of a president as a leader,
a picture of a specific
guy. It's, it was actually,
it still flashes into my mind.
It's, it's a picture of a,
of a silhouette of a male
presidential profile.
Like maybe the idea of
a president basically.
So that was our president and then I
had to figure out a United States then.
So yeah, eventually I come
up with this map in my mind,
this picture of the United States
and like the line drawings.
Now she's got this map, she's got
the silhouette of a guy and she said,
after hours, president United States,
President United States. And I was like,
oh my God. She still couldn't
somehow bring him together.
I didn't have the road that I had
to travel in order to come up with.
Um, I think it was Clinton at the time.
Yeah, it was Clinton at the time. No,
as Jill starts to get better,
this is after eight years
of hard work and recovery.
And finally the words start to
trickle back. And when they did,
she says that silence that she
loved so much got pushed out.
That was one of the sacrifices for
me. That was one of the sacrifices.
Wow. Oh Wow.
We're doing a, we're doing
a language show here a year.
The auntie queen of our language. So
you're like same Clooney, it's it.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
But what I am saying is that in order
for us to communicate with language,
we pull ourselves away from a
different kind of experience.
I do believe that there are
times when you need to let your,
your brain chatter be quiet.
But is it fair to say this is like,
please agree or disagree
with this statement?
I think that words and language
and grammar are necessary,
but not half as good as wind in my hair
as smelling my nose and that old right
brain sensual immediacy.
Yeah. You know, if,
um, if I had to choose,
which is essentially what you're
saying, if I had to choose, um,
that would be really, really,
really tough decision.
[inaudible].
Jill Bolte Taylor is the author
of, uh, what's it called?
The book my stroke of insight.
Yes. Check our website,
radiolab.org for any details, and
if you subscribe to our podcast,
there is a bonus video that goes along
with this hour and it's pretty great.